cher nathalie dans notre grande série
des dégradés nous allons maintenant
passer commencé le mardi matin et par
gramme de constipation ballonnements
maintenant ces minots c'est ménopause
c'est la ménopause
quand on aime on ne compte pas voici
quelques conseils patricia peut-on
cumuler chômage et bénévolat mais
jusqu'au bout je crois qu'en fait nous
allons passer à la rubrique juridique de
roland perez et puis nous irons sur
patricia enfin sur patricia retourne
chez papa et ses amis qu on n'avait pas
une petite barbe
moi j'ai une grosse blind bon on sait
qu'anne venez y est je crois que ça va
on essaie
on les aide et spontanée voyez-vous la
spontanéité voyez où ça mène